inside this brussels monolith the
european commission has been planning
coming up with its answer to the most
enduring political problem of brexit
what to do about northern ireland
because the nation is in a unique
position still part of the european
single market but also freely trading
goods with the rest of britain
it's a complex new status and everyone
agrees it's created problems with goods
moving in and out
and then there's this the european court
of justice the brexit minister lord
frost says it should have no power over
northern ireland the eu disagrees very
strongly
today brussels chief negotiator offered
a string of compromises but there was no
talk of removing the power of the court
i believe that what we presented today
is such an appealing picture that we
would really focus all our constructive
and creative energy
how to make this
as good as possible
for the people and businesses in
northern ireland and i hope
that
lord frost will join me in that effort
the european commission is proposing to
cut 80 percent of checks made on a
variety of british goods heading into
northern ireland
this includes items such as
confectionery dairy products fish and
yes cumberland sausages
the plan would also ensure the free flow
of medicines between great britain and
northern ireland
while customs paperwork will be halved
and more goods would be declared low
risk meaning they could be transported
faster
but the oversight of the european court
of justice would remain
problem with the the protocol at the
moment is that eu law is
with the ecj uh as the enforcer of it uh
is applied in northern ireland without
any sort of democratic process
so that i think has to change
the european commission has made some
significant concessions to such an
extent that some people in this building
think they've gone too far that they've
been too generous to the british
government what that means is that most
people agree there's not much wriggle
room left one senior diplomat told me he
considered this offer to be a take it or
leave it deal
on the other side of the border they are
keen on a deal
if everyone is operating in good faith
and if the focus is on addressing
disruption in trade between northern
ireland and great britain
then these proposals address the problem
and respect the treaties we all agreed
to
everyone agrees they want this sorted
but as every brexit veteran knows the
hunt for a compromise can go down to the
wire
adam parsons sky news brussels